ping franchement cette année on attend
du très bon niveau e
on sait ce qu'il en est de l'équipe 2 du
goëlo qui est annoncé comme comme un
véritable du couvent paye surtout après
leur victoire contre les trolls de noël
ce qui est archi favori depuis très
longtemps donc c'est nous donner l'eau
qui vient d'en servir et qu'ils ont donc
bien mérité leur qualification
chez les filles bien baissé à éliminer
un ami cher donc ça veut dire que la
hausse il ya du niveau et puis si la
mariée
indécrottable soit c'est le sinnamary de
l'équipe de cinéma et qu'on connaît bien
quoi et puis laissez là ton qui depuis
un moment
produit du très bon basket donc chez
nous nos équipes
la gauloise et le golden 1 on nous voit
relever un véritable défi et je pense
qu'elles se sont préparés en conséquence
elles sont à domicile elles ont un
charme supplémentaire à relever je
compte succès des équipes là pour que la
fête soit d'abord que la fête soit belle
que ce soit un très beau tournoi
et puis derrière on est de bon goût de
magnifiques représentants où la
nationale 3 cette année le tournoi une
consonance particulière à paris la
fédération organise les choses petit peu
différente y aura des tas de
représentants
du sénat et de toute autre organisation
qui organise institutions politiques
vous savez que on est dans nos grandes
discussions et le sénat a mis en place
une commission à laquelle participe la
sénatrice catherine catherine conconne
sur les infrastructures sportives dans
nos départements et dans nos régions et
dans nos collectivités
c'est un gros sujet sur lequel on va
devoir aussi apporter notre pierre à
l'édifice et et montrer montrer ce qu'on
fait de bien et les besoins qu'on a